bienvenidos a 5 minutos o con nos
acompaña daniel cano coordinador
político de la iniciativa barómetro del
instituto creo que una de las
instituciones encargadas de evaluar el
cumplimiento del histórico acuerdo de
paz en colombia' con la ex guerrilla de
las farc que cumple por estos días
cuatro años de firmado daniel buen día
para ustedes y cuatro años después bajo
el gobierno de iván duque del centro
democrático claro opositor del acuerdo
que balances en ustedes se ha descuidado
lo pactado por parte del gobierno o como
se le critica que tanto se ha avanzado
en la implementación
hola buenos días
nosotros hacemos un balance de la
implementación analizando los 578
compromisos que el instituto creo que
monitorea como parte del mandato que
recibió por las partes y el balance es
que durante estos cuatro años se ha
avanzado fundamentalmente con la
creación de la arquitectura
institucional para la implementación del
acuerdo lo que tiene que ver con las
entidades que hacen parte por ejemplo el
sistema de integral de verdad justicia
reparación y no repetición
todo el proceso muy exitoso de cese al
fuego dejación de armas unos espacios
iniciales de reincorporación temprana
como lo fue la creación de los espacios
territoriales de capacitación y
reincorporación donde se ubicaron las
farc en su momento y se ha avanzado con
unos temas básicos en la creación y en
la implementación de los demás puntos
del acuerdo sin embargo vemos unos retos
significativos sobre todo porque lo que
se ha avanzado hasta el momento no es no
tiene ese potencial transformador que se
espera que tenga el acuerdo aunque hay
que tener en cuenta que apenas vamos en
el cuarto año y este acuerdo tiene un
horizonte de 15 años para su
implementación entonces aquí están
pendientes temas como por ejemplo
el punto 1 que tiene que ver con la
reforma rural que es un punto que se
espera que pueda resolver muchas de las
causas estructurales del conflicto como
el acceso a la tierra por ejemplo bueno
en abril del 2018 la fiscalía colombiana
acusó al ex guerrillero jesús santrich
de un intento de exportar cocaína a eeuu
esto lo llevó a él ya otro destacado
dirigente de las farc a abandonar el
proceso y retomar las armas ahora
recientes denuncias periodísticas
señalan al entonces fiscal néstor
humberto martínez como autor de un
entrampamiento en este caso asestándole
una estocada al acuerdo y ha despertado
oposición a su posible nombramiento como
embajador en españa qué opinión le
merece a usted todo este caso
vemos que el instituto no hace un
análisis de la coyuntura política que
sea a partir de estos sucesos nosotros
destacamos las reacciones que tuvieron
en su momento tanto el gobierno como las
farc frente a la salida o el abandono
del proceso por parte de jesús santrich
cuestionándolo por haberse apartado de
ese compromiso de la de la firma del
acuerdo pero como te digo este tema de
la coyuntura política frente a lo que
implica estas decisiones y lo que
general no hace parte digamos del
análisis que realizamos nosotros en el
instituto bueno sin embargo estamos de
acuerdo en que al menos como denuncia es
muy grave que un ex fiscal del país
pudiera estar involucrado en un daño a
propósito del acuerdo de paz
como denuncia claro como tema digamos de
relevancia para el país es un tema
importante es un tema que tienen que
analizar las autoridades y investigar si
este tema se ha dado cómo se está
planteando efectivamente lo importante
aquí es
como te decía la respuesta conjunta que
ha habido tanto por parte del gobierno
como por parte de el componente farc o
del partido farc de continuar avanzando
con la implementación del acuerdo y
creemos que ese es uno de los temas que
es de destacar porque lo que hemos visto
en otros contextos internacionales de
los 30 acuerdos 34 pues acuerdo de paz
que analizamos es que el acuerdo es muy
reciente ha soportado estos procesos
incluso de crisis o de dificultad como
el que se presentó con santrich y las
partes siguen comprometidas en la
implementación y nos quedan solamente
unos pocos segundos muy rápidamente les
quiero pedir su opinión sobre lo que ha
sucedido con la gestión de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz
claro que sí el último año nosotros
destacamos el avance del sistema
integral de verdad justicia y reparación
específicamente la jurisdicción especial
para la paz la unidad de personas
desaparecidas y la comisión para el
esclarecimiento de la verdad en avanzar
con los compromisos que tienen para las
víctimas de hecho los avances recientes
en el tema de los macro casos que tienen
abiertos y sobre todo la participación
con más de 200 testimonios de
combatientes de las farc para ayudar a
ubicar personas desaparecidas en el
marco del conflicto es un tema muy
importante aquí quedan unos retos
significativos sobre todo en empezar a
dar resultados muy concretos y la
articulación que tiene esto con el el
sistema de la ley 1448 de víctimas con
colom
sí muchísimas gracias a ustedes y a
nuestros televidentes que siguen con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]